all right Iraq is a total freaking mess
you probably have heard about that so
right now Isis which is the Islamic
state in Iraq and Syria or ISIL as
President Obama's calling it the Islamic
state in Iraq and the Levant is
basically marching through Iraq they've
split the country pretty much into three
territories all based on uh you know
sectarian stop and the Sunni and the
Shia and all that stuff okay I want to
get to too deep into it cuz we're not
policy wonks here uh but uh president
obama said that he wasn't going to send
any troops we've now said 275 troops to
secure our embassy which people don't
know the embassy in Baghdad is the
biggest US Embassy in the world there
are five thousand US citizens that work
there uh there may be limited drone
strikes it's all sort of on unfolding
very quickly so again we are not experts
in security but that's why I'm doing the
show to have sort of normal people talk
about the broader issues um what should
we do solve it for us right now that was
a big one no pressure uh I was just
gonna say bring in archer if any of your
archer fans blow that Isis figured
that's an Isis reference yeah I I don't
I I don't know I don't know what to do
and I it doesn't matter if you're
listening to am talk FM talk everybody's
talking about this and nobody knows what
to do so if they don't know and they get
paid to figure it out ishares yeah wait
are you saying that we shouldn't be
listening to the same people the
architects of the original Iraq war
right now cuz all those guys they're all
showing up all over the place yeah this
is the time shine let me do it try to
make it work this time why is it that
when they put these people back on the
cable news channels they don't put under
their names [ __ ] up the first yeah
yeah royally [ __ ] Bill Kristol expert no
expert exactly yeah so really what what
do you think we should do I mean look
it's a freaky this is a disaster this
could cause this could cause Jordan to
fall also I mean this is just the
beginning 275 troops obviously maybe can
defend our embassy but can't defend a
country and does it even matter should
we just let them all kill each other do
yeah exactly do we is that our role to
take care of that I don't think so i
don't know i was trying to read through
all
the facts and I can't ingest it's just
so heavy but I do agree that we need the
troops there to protect our people and
that's why I was saying before as a
politician you want to stay babe because
he said no troops and then he had to
send some in and it's like hey you're
going back on your word but at the end
of the day I think their goal is the
goal that we should all be worried about
protecting our people that are there
everything else I just kind of want to
stay out of because it's just it'll only
come back on us and then we're in
another war so I basically agree with
you like there's nothing we can do these
people have hated each other forever
this is goes beyond us but we did throw
a bomb literally when we went to war
there so should we do we feel are we
guilty you're not even shoot our guilty
conscience lead us back into cleaning up
anything as if we even if it was
remotely possible that we could order we
just say that the whole place now that
we can do is are we screwed up sorry and
that's the thing I mean I don't mean to
oversimplify but that's exactly what I'm
gonna do I mean it's lonely at the top
you know and when we do go in we're
bullies when we don't go in or heartless
yeah so I don't know why what makes this
situation different than every other
situation that we've been struggling
with do we do we try to fix it or do we
stay out of it because either way we're
gonna be in trouble yeah what do you
make of it go ahead as I say and make it
worse yeah who says we're gonna fix it
like if even if we'd send everyone in
there's no guarantee that we'll fix it
it's probably gonna into far worse yeah
what are you guys making the general
theme in the country would see which
seems to be that we should be pulling
back from the rest of the world you know
II mean like that everything happened in
Ukraine we're not even talking about
Ukraine anymore we've sort of lost in
terms of what we said was supposed to
happen I mean Russia pretty much one
okay what do you think of there's the
general feeling in the United States
like that we sort of don't have a role
anymore which is sort of what Obama
promised he said we're gonna step back
right and then and that's what's that
wouldn't want our promise don't yeah we
want the promise even if there's a lot
of bad [ __ ] happen right I think you
just get to a point where you're fed up
and like just like we're talking right
now we're overwhelmed we don't think we
can fix anything why why put ourselves
in a position to make it far worse for
them and for us it's like let's just
wash our hands step away and reshipped
our focus because there's things here we
need to work on yeah and I don't think
we want to use our resources for outside
outside problems right is they
anyone that use watch on TV on any of
the news channels that you really trust
when it comes to this is there any
politician that when they come on you
feel like they really know what they're
talking about or have you seen scandal
they're all lines I haven't seen Stella
but i watch i watch me penthouse a card
that gives a pretty good sense what's
gone into it they're all right i mean is
there any way that you watch then you're
like this guy really has ironically joe
biden when he was running for president
in 2008 before he joined obama he was
the one saying that there's this country
needs to be split into three things babe
which is crazy because everyone thinks
the guys completely nuts now but uh
uncle jack crazy crazy uncle joe and he
was making this point way back then but
really is there anyone that you know is
i say i do then i end up looking like an
idiot because it's because they they
they're so relatable or they're so
charming and they're just they're folksy
and i like that but it doesn't end up
mattering I don't know what they know
they only know what they want me to know
so I always end up feeling stupid anyway
I agree with your lack of sight